hello so we should first decide what
we're talking about we're not talking
about my views of political correctness
despite what you might have inferred
from the last speakers comments this is
how it looks to me we essentially need
something approximating a low resolution
grand narrative to unite us and and we
need a narrative tonight is because
otherwise we don't have peace what's
playing out in the Universities and in
broader society right now is a debate
between two fundamental low resolution
narratives neither of which can be
completely accurate because they can't
encompass all the details obviously
human beings have an individual element
and a collective element a group element
let's say the question is what story
should be paramount and this is how it
looks to me in the West we have
reasonably functional reasonably free
remarkably productive stable hierarchies
that are open to consideration of the
dispossessed that hierarchies generally
create our societies are freer and
functioning more effectively than any
societies anywhere else in the world and
that and then any societies ever have
and as far as I'm concerned and I think
there's good reason to assume this it's
because the fundamental low resolution
grand narrative that we've oriented
ourselves around in the West is one of
the sovereignty of the individual and
it's predicated on the idea that all
things considered the best way for me to
interact with someone else is individual
to individual and to react to that
person as if they're both part of the
process because that's the right way of
thinking about it the psychological
process by which things we don't
understand can yet be explored and by
things that aren't properly organized in
our society can be yet set right the
reason we're valuable as individuals
both with regards to our rights and
responsibilities is because that's our
essential purpose and that's our
nobility and that's our function what's
happening as far as I'm concerned in the
universities in particular and spreading
very
Lyoto into the broader world including
the corporate world much too it's much
to what should be its chagrin is a
collectivist narrative and of course
there's some utility in a collectivist
narrative because we're all part of
groups in different ways but the
collectivist narrative that I regard as
politically correct is a pastiche of a
strange pastiche of post-modernism and
neo Marxism and it's fundamental claim
is that no you're not essentially an
individual you're essentially a member
of a group and that group might be your
ethnicity and it might be your sex and
it might be a race and it might be any
of the endless numbers of other
potential groups that you belong to
because you belong to many of them and
that you should be essentially
categorized along with those who are
like you on that dimension in that group
that's proposition number one
proposition number two is that the
proper way to view the world is as a
battleground between groups of different
power so you define the group's first
and then you assume that you you you
view the individual from the group
context you view the battle between
groups from the group context and you
view history itself as a consequence of
nothing but the power maneuvers between
different groups that eliminates any
consideration of the individual and at a
very fundamental level and also any idea
for example of free speech because if
your collectivist at heart in this
manner there is no such thing as free
speech it isn't that it's debated by
those on the radical left and let's say
the rest of us so to speak it's that in
that formulation there's no such thing
as free speech because for an
individualist free speech is how you
make sense of the world in reorganize
Society in a proper manner but for the
radical left type collectivist that's
associated with this viewpoint of
political correctness when you speak all
you're doing is playing a power game on
behalf of your group and there's nothing
else that you can do because that's all
there is and not only is that all there
is in terms of who you are as an
individual now and how society should be
viewed it's also the fundamental
narrative of history for example it's
it's widely assumed in our universities
now that the best way to conceptualize
Western civilization is as an oppressive
male-dominated patriarchy and that the
best way to construe relationships
between men and women across the
centuries is one of oppression of women
by men that's like well look no
hierarchy is without its tyranny that's
a that's an axiomatic truth people have
recognized that literally for thousands
of years and hierarchies do tend towards
tyranny and they tend towards the
usurpation by people with power but that
only happens when they become corrupt we
have mechanisms in our society to stop
hierarchies from becoming intolerably
corrupt and they actually work pretty
well and so and so I would also I would
also I would also point this out you
know don't be thinking that this is a
debate about whether empathy is useful
or not or that the people on the con
side of the argument are not empathetic
I know perfectly well as I'm sure mr.
Frey does that hierarchies tend to
produce situations where people stack up
at the bottom and that the dispossessed
in hierarchies need a political voice
which is the proper voice of the left by
the way and the necessary voice of the
left but that is not the same as
proclaiming that the right level of
analysis for our grand unifying
narrative is that all of us are
fundamentally to be identified by the
groups that we belong to and to construe
the entire world as the battleground
between different forms of tyranny in
consequence of that group affiliation
and to the degree that we play out that
narrative that won't be progress believe
me and we certainly haven't seen that
progress in the universities we've seen
situations like what happened in Wilfred
Laurier University instead we won't see
progress what we'll return to is exactly
the same kind of tribalism to
characterize the lamp